all right everyone here we are it is a
new week and we may have something a
little different on our hands today we
now actually have drama related to
whether these briefings or today's is
actually being rebranded a press
conference we're going to happen we have
questions as to whether any reporters
will be allowed to ask questions during
the press briefings and I just don't
know the answer so let me give you guys
the backstory on it as you might
remember last Thursday Donald Trump made
this completely abortive globally
shameful comment about injecting
disinfectants quick reminder we hid the
body it's about the tremendous whether
it is ultra violet or just very powerful
light right and I think you said that
hasn't been checked but you're gonna
test it and then I said supposing you
brought the light inside the body you
can which you can do either through the
skin or in some other way right and I
think you said you're gonna test that
too sounds interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
Britt knocks it out in a minute one
minute and is there a way we can do
something like that by injection inside
okay injection inside disinfect an
injection inside it obviously happened
Trump tried saying it was sarcastic on
Friday but clearly that wasn't going to
work and so during the Friday press
briefing Mike Pence just wrapping up and
then they just leave not taking
questions for the first time since the
start of the virus I truly do believe
the day will soon come when we will heal
our land and I will be able to reopen
America and put this great nation back
to work
[Music]
now you hear caitlin collins from CNN
saying mr. president is now the time for
sarcasm because of course he earlier
claimed ridiculously that he was being
sarcastic when he said let's look at
some injections and then after this not
taking questions no press conference on
saturday no press conference on sunday
amid reports that these are going to be
dramatically scaled down which makes
sense
they're just libeled and it seems that
they just create situations for donald
trump to say things that make the entire
world laugh at him which is very very
triggering for him but then today we
woke up and there was a press briefing
scheduled for 5:00 p.m. until it was
cancelled and replaced with a rose
garden presentation with trump and pence
so i don't know what to expect i think
it's perfectly plausible that it will be
an outdoor thing at the Rose Garden set
up with Trump and pence alone on a stage
making a statement and then walking out
I wouldn't be surprised if that's what
happens I also wouldn't be surprised if
they figured out some way to say we will
only take questions about economic
issues for example because that's
another thing that was leaked over the
weekend that they would shift the focus
from talking about the virus which is
what's killing people of course to
talking only about economics maybe
that's a possibility there's a rumor
floating around that Trump will announce
a plan to test 2% of the population now
that can't be it right because let's
just do some simple math let's see if we
have our Monday data yet we do oh my god
a total failure in testing today we
actually had a few successful days where
we were getting up over 300 thousand
tests close to two over to close to
three over to only a hundred and
thirty-five thousand tested today so
we've currently tested 5.6 million
people this is a country of 331 million
so think about it this way 1% is 3.3
million 2% is 6.6 million
Trump announcing that we will we will be
testing 2% of the population
we only need to test 700,000 more like
we're gonna get to that by Friday no
matter what Trump says is he going to
announce a way to test two percent of
the population per day that would be
something right if we could do six point
six million tests per day that would be
something
we're obviously nowhere near that we
tested a hundred and thirty five
thousand today so I don't know what's
going to be announced Trump's new press
secretary weaponized propagandist Kaylie
McKenna nee who's very devoutly
Christian and I can't imagine Jesus
would be okay with all the lying she
does
she said Donald Trump is gonna be making
some major announcement about testing
protocol or something like that today so
I have no idea what's going to happen
today but we will soon see the latest
official numbers are globally we have
now hit three million cases the real
number is probably somewhere between six
and sixty million cases somewhere in
there we don't really know two hundred
and eleven thousand deaths in the United
States we did today surpassed 1 million
official cases remember Trump just weeks
ago saying we have 15 cases they will
soon be 0 we are also just a few days
from 60,000 deaths remember the White
House for weeks now predicting our total
death toll would be 60,000 we appear to
be just a few days just a few days from
that number
17,000 new cases today a thousand new
deaths if you want some good news I will
mention that yesterday we had the lowest
death toll that you have to go all the
way back to March 31st to find a lower
death toll than yesterday that's good
it may just be a blip again because we
still have three hours left in the day
as measured on this website which resets
at GMT midnight we're already at the
same number of deaths that's what I can
tell you um now I do want to talk
briefly and depending on the timing of
all of this I may talk about this after
the briefing I actually have some ideas
about what should happen over the next
six weeks that are probably a little
more practical than just a total and
complete shutdown and there's
psychological and economic
reasons for it but I want to make sure I
have the time for that so so we'll take
a pause on that welcome to everybody
watching on Twitter twitch YouTube and
Facebook
I do have amazing news for folks I did a
time-lapse of my tomato plants this is a
two hour time lapse and as you can see
look at this little guy
stretching up towards the Sun rising
like a phoenix an incredible win in the
battle of ideas this weekend my tomato
plants are very very much in play so to
speak and anyway I don't know just just
a little little levity for us here
nothing better I also have some sprouted
herbs and herbs cucumbers are starting
to rise through the ashes and a
resurrection like a motif I guess I
would call it but very very exciting
stuff happening in the world of
gardening which I encourage people to
check out this is of course indoors
these will be moved outside around
Mother's Day around Mother's days is
sort of my expectation if you're just
joining me on Twitch welcome I had to
physically fight off my staff today to
get them to allow me to stream on Twitch
because the twitch subs have been
imploding and there is a rising
[Music]
perspective at the David Pakman show
that I should pinch off twitch
altogether and forsake twitch to the
list of prior platforms I refuse to do
that so I fought off my staff today and
we are live on Twitch and I want to say
thanks to Drew Noah for gifting a
subscription actually too and also to
poo be for signing up with twitch Prime
on any number of YouTube super chats are
coming in please remember if you're
joining me on YouTube smash that
subscribe button I mean absolutely turn
it into mashed potatoes and also use the
like button both are very much
appreciated zesty African asks do you
appreciate the leaders in the pink tide
movement if so what about them it's
that's not a movement I'm familiar with
nanny of many has signed up on YouTube
marita lez says David from
recommends for coronavirus to drink
bleach Trump has gone totally
schizophrenic
Zachary Foster says Cuomo says events
happening in the summer are vital for
people's sanity can you go a little
further and explain how New York City
can accomplish this I listen I have a
whole rant about that I will try to get
to it today and if not I will do it
tomorrow I am making dinner tonight and
there's a very explosive situation in my
fridge right now so I don't have
unlimited time today but if Trump is
relatively short in speaking today which
he might be if he doesn't take questions
I will address that very much head on
parity Ren says David I saw your hanging
lock of hair on the forehead it's so
1990 a--the just kidding you look fine
okay
Adrien benningfield says David if the
bleacher and theif cancels pressors will
you do a live stream still yeah if Trump
no longer does press briefings because
we need to because YouTube revenue is
down 35% I mean this is a very real
economic situation for us I will
probably start streaming I will do like
a sampling of what governors are doing
so like I would go to Andrew Cuomo I
would go to Gavin Newsom I would go
maybe to Mike DeWine Charlie Baker we
would we would do something like that
and I'll make tuna melts live on on
camera as well
holy fook says how bad if a president
was Ronald Reagan that that's not for
today that's not for today um black
weigh 54 says she in there making panini
she no I got all the bread she know me
got it I'm a hustler yeah yow it's lit
god I hope that's not racist Tina Howard
says David why should the average
American be concerned about the oil
surplus lower cost for us is good
Halliburton losing money doesn't bother
me right in the question would be
whether it would be part of a
deflationary spiral that would be a
bigger thing than just oil and will it
depress wages will it impact the ability
of small businesses to make money there
there are other concerns but you're
right if gas is cheap that's not
obviously a concern for you for sure
let's see here Shane Busta
says keep on growing yeah we're gonna
keep growing plants for sure
Miz Smith says protesters comparing
lockdown as slavery stupid yes but the
mentality of this what are your thoughts
I have a segment about that on today's
show so let me not sort of outdo myself
by talking about that now but clip
coming up soon hair tearin' says to see
something grow is comforting in the face
of disease yes that is why it is just
inspirational to see my little tomato
plants every day every day just pulling
pulling pulling towards the Sun just a
little bit and very very exciting and we
are going to have much more on my urban
garden very very soon I trust Jays
reviews sends a super chat nasty
questions says I'm nervous there will be
no nasty questions today me too I am
very nervous about it by the way does
anybody know if any stream now is live
in the Rose Garden because I would much
rather be able to see how close we are
to the start of this insanity and Fox
News tends to go live first I prefer the
c-span feed but they aren't live either
I don't know if anybody is aware of
another stream I would love to find one
that is just camping out in the Rose
Garden if we can taking a quick look
here and not seeing one and nobody is
directing me to one either maybe oh wait
a second the White House the White House
is also not live but I guess I can add
that just to our arsenal here in case
they do go live sooner yeah I guess I
guess nobody's life yeah we're not sure
at this point in time we'll stick with
Fox just because they tend to go live
pretty early okay holy fook says did you
see the Harvard caps Harris Poll that
shows 20% of registered voters prefer
Sanders for Weiden beef VP slot which is
the highest I did not see that I did not
see that but I will look at that BW 85
asks if these are
heirloom tomatoes they are not they they
are not or heirloom now holy fook says
what are the Joe Biden sexual assault
accusations ok we've gone through that a
whole bunch of times
holy fook is this user previously known
as rat packer previously known as
Kenneth Steven Steven Kenneth destiny
Bunnell previously known as dr. Anthony
Fauci previously known as Hugh Jass and
they try to just derail the streams
constantly Daniel Krieger says I'm
troubled with violent thoughts these
days I'm a I would I would talk to a
professional about that
Mike Valverde says how can I earn a
follow on Twitter it's tough I follow
very few people on Twitter very very few
oh one other thing we are also told that
the doctors will be sort of taking a
back seat
going forward during these press
briefings and we people are asking you
know we haven't seen foul Chi for a week
what about that I don't know that we
will see Burks either I think that the
doctors are gonna have an increasingly
small role during these they are gonna
be focusing on a propagandistic economic
message because I think they believe
that it would be useful to them people
keep dying though I don't I don't know
that it's gonna be appropriate to ignore
that plinky winky says is America now a
second world country since one of the
conditions for first world is to have a
stable Democratic leader you know I
don't know about first or second world
but the United States is listed in the
democracy index as a flawed democracy
not a full democracy so that that
characterization has been in place for a
little while we are two spots below
South Korea two spots less democratic
than South Korea despite regularly
having a trump administration officials
say we are not authoritarian like South
Korea we can't do what they did around
the virus they are ranked higher in the
democracy index than we are
Fox Johnson says one of the leaders of
reopened North Carolina tested positive
didn't see that Christian birdie L says
I'm afraid to say this but I wonder what
will be the next suggestion that Trump
will give rat poison I
Trump at this point is going to stay
away from from such irresponsible
suggestions that's my guess that's my
guess
holy fook says why would you have the
idiot you're right now you know we're
not doing that homonyms of other people
other youtubers we just don't do it
Maddie I speedy says governor Geena
Raimundo rolled out a comprehensive
reintegration plan today perhaps a piece
for your show she has done an
exceptional job thus far please email
that to me if you can through my website
I would like to look at that um Andrew
Moore says Pennsylvania Governor wolf
vetoed an override of the stay at home
order a week ago single-handedly saving
thousands of lives no one mentions his
courageous actions let me say a huge
huge thank you to die hard 246 for
subscribing on Twitch July hippo July
hippo subscribes with the message
flattened the implosion curve mechanics
has subscribed on Twitch as has ml Smith
elf 1491 subscribes on twitch with the
message thank you for all you do I
always keep up with my free twitch subs
and love my website subscription stay
safe and sane Thank You multibeast says
had to take my wife to MGH in Chelsea
today scary site with all the co vid
tents in the parking lot
yeah a number of friends of mine are
emergency room doctors in the city and
I've been hearing similar situations
water girl has subscribed on Twitch
saying thanks for keeping me sane during
these afternoon nut fests yeah indeed
remember anybody with Amazon Prime can
subscribe free on Twitch absolutely free
on Twitch you pay nothing we get a
little bit of money which is very very
exciting we believe that we are
potentially just seconds from the start
of this news conference although we
don't even have live video yet if at any
point anybody gets an update about
what's going on let's see if Trump has
tweeted anything about it
I will be having a press conference at
5:30 oh okay very good well there is the
update now we know exactly what is going
on that tells us that welcome of course
if you are watching on Facebook or
Twitter we've been sort of beta testing
for lack of a better term streaming on
Twitter as well as on Facebook and it
goes okay sometimes we actually have end
up with more viewers on Facebook than on
twitch I don't know what the rhymer
sometimes we have a fraction sometimes
we have more I don't know and Twitter is
still not not doing great Twitter is
still not doing great usually like a
hundred people watch on Twitter but I
figure why not do it right it costs us
nothing extra to do it and you know and
that means yeah
Twitter streaming a lot of people
laughing at it but why not why not okay
info minimal says Trump equals dark
order orange cassidy equals corona cure
okay BK says channel ab Aqaba
coronavirus are the lock downs actually
working April 21st update great visuals
and stat analysis of bell curve and
analysis of infectious prediction very
good
Jamal Swift says hey homie what will it
take for you to sing happy birthday it's
my birthday i I don't know that I'm
equipped to do that I really can't sing
but I happy birthday to you Jamal Jamal
checks in with a super chat on almost
every single one of my live streams
really appreciate it Jamal have a good
birthday probably a slightly different
birthday than many given what's going on
but hopefully a good one
nonetheless my friend your boy blue says
trump is a scary orange man zesty
African says pink tide meaning leaders
like Chavez Morales Lula Kirchner Correa
zalaya Obrador etcetera do you fancy any
of them and do you fear their shift to
the right Latin America is experiencing
I'm not a I'm not a big Shabbos fan it's
certainly not a Kershner fan and I think
from these maybe obrador is the one I
would I would be most at most in favor
of
Reynaldo Martinez sends a super chat
Daniel Rivera says how much do David
Pakman show shares go for I now own all
the shares as many of you know we at one
point had some angel investors in the
show back in 2008 2017 back in late 2015
we in order to expand the show
dramatically and bring on additional
full-time staff and yada yada yada we
took on three silent minority investors
by minority I don't mean that they were
racial minorities maybe they were maybe
they weren't I'm not identifying them
one way or the other
but they they owned a minority of the
shares and that provided an injection
not of bleach but of capital to the
program to expand our studio go HD and
hire full-time staff all this stuff so
for a while I did not own all of the
shares of the David Pakman show Holding
Corporation over the last year I have
bought out hello I have bought out those
shareholders and I am back to 100% 100%
ownership of the David Pakman show but
of course it's pretty academic because
at all times I was 100% in control
editorially importantly but so shares
are essentially priceless Daniel they
are not for sale at this point in time
Johnnie Minogue says after watching your
narrations of the daily briefings not
per capita is the new safe word de jour
yes indeed very much so very very much
so as we stand by here let me say a huge
thank you to a very special person that
person is Matt Kelly why is Matt Kelly
so special well there's probably a lot
of reasons but the one I know of is that
Matt Kelly just signed up at join
pakman.com and is new member number one
for today's livestream as you can see
we've just filled the tiniest little
slice to quote Andrew yang of this blue
bar right above my head I have been very
successfully limiting my membership
enticements
just one per stream so let me just do it
right now and get it out of the way
we're having a real tough month when it
comes to our members members our primary
source of funding we lost 389 389 in
March why we all know why 20% of the
countries out of work people are
tightening the belts I get it this is
not as important as food so I get it
this month were already up to close to
another 350 or so people who have
canceled we still have four days left
today maybe even this month maybe even
worse than March so we're all in it
together I don't want anybody's last
dollar I've made the commitment that
we're not cutting ours we're not laying
people off we've decentralized work so
production can continue my ask to you is
a very simple one if you are in the
umbrella of folks that can afford one or
two dollars a month consider getting a
membership at join pakman.com if you use
that coupon code above my head it's two
bucks a month or only a dollar 80 a
month if you pay for the entire year or
if you prefer and some people do make a
pledge on patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show everything counts
today okay the goal is 25 memberships
count patreon counts if you up your
patreon pledge that'll count if you're
pledging two bucks a month and you
double it to four to become that'll
count everything counts and everybody
will get thanked profusely by me during
the stream I won't interrupt the press
briefing for it but I will thank
everybody one way or the other that's
the that's the gist I guess of what I'm
telling you okay the press briefing has
been cancelled and replaced with a Rose
Garden press conference whether that
will or won't include questions to
Donald Trump I don't know the funny
thing about avoiding questions to not
have to talk about bleach injections is
that at some point he will have to take
a question in the rest of his presidency
right and reporters not going to forget
that he never answered questions about
bleach injections so we'll see if there
are questions answered today it has also
been moved from
p.m. to 5:30 top of the hour to the
bottom of the hour so that's what we're
currently standing by for a very poor
day in testing today it looked like we
were going in the right direction last
Wednesday we tested three 15 K almost
200,000 on Thursday over 200,000 on
Friday close to 300 on Saturday 200 and
this is still we've got to get to 500 K
a day minimum and then today only a
hundred and thirty-five thousand tests
so things are not going well as far as
that's concerned
Trump reportedly going to tell us
something today about a testing protocol
a few twitch thank-yous before I get
back to Super chats I want to make sure
I don't miss pronounce any of these
usernames strontium 54 has subscribed on
twitch frizzy fry has subscribed beard
Beardsley is a new twitch Prime member
our go nut is a new twitch Prime member
dead dead Lowe's has subscribed hummus
sexual I can only imagine what it is
like to be around a chickpea for someone
named hummus sexual has subscribed our
roon Antony has subscribed Mertz bow has
cheered Angeles Co has subscribed
dragonfly back home
is a new subscriber on twitch John
Callie as well gray Keys has cheered and
Andre the Bavarian Andre the vApp
ovarian all of those people I just made
up their names none of them actually
just subscribed
no I'm kidding they are all too real all
too real alright let's get back over to
some YouTube super chats remember if
you're watching on youtube please
subscribe folks this is my please clap
moment please remember to subscribe and
like the stream it's all free I mean
it's completely free there's there's no
plausible reason on God's green earth to
borrow a term from people that I don't
really know not to like and subscribe
because it's free
the buttons are free to use okay Anthony
Sanchez says hola me number espero you
know
yeah the Pedro saga continues it
continues Charlie says woke up in a cold
sweat last night had a nightmare that
the David Pakman show was no more not an
exaggeration to say I'm not sure I would
get through this without your coverage
never stop hashtag smashed that like
along with a delightful $50 super chat
from Charlie thanks Charlie I appreciate
that very much I really do your boy blue
you know Charlie I had a nightmare last
night that you were no longer sending
super chats and that was really the
nightmare that I woke up in a cold sweat
from your boy blue says is Trump going
to snort Clorox bleach on live TV you
know I made over the weekend I had a
zoom zoom hangout with some of my
friends we played some jackbox TV games
which I recommend to you not a sponsor
just a genuine suggestion quip lash is
one of the most fun ones and I actually
made a delightful cocktail it's um
one you basically use it's one part
vodka and it's got to be a really good
vodka I like what vodkas do I like I
guess I shouldn't even really say but
they're you know I think we people can
probably guess what vodka I like and
it's so it's one part vodka one part
Clorox bleach and I put an orange rind
in it and then you just do a spray of
Lysol just a single spray of just around
the rim because you don't want to be
drinking the Lysol but it's just more
for the aromatics of it delightful
delightful
I'm completely kidding I'm completely
kidding do not do that Andrae see says
David do you think Trump will use a real
war with China as an excuse to cancel
November elections remember Trump can't
cancel November elections it's up to
States Trump can direct states to
postpone whether they would or wouldn't
I don't know I I think Trump is likely
to use military conflict to justify his
re-election I don't think it's likely
Trump will use military conflict to try
to postpone the
election but you know I've been wrong
many times before and I could very well
be wrong again let me say a few other
thank-yous Gregory Bowers is new member
number two today at join pakman.com mike
Saltz is new member number 3 Denham
haunches has more than doubled their
patreon pledge so we're gonna call that
number 4 Michael Hanson is new member
number 5 at join pakman.com Christopher
munos is new member number 6 today Brian
Williams has made a pledge on patreon so
Brian is number 7 Vince
stanky is number 8 at join pakman.com on
and in weimar is new member number 9
today Lisa Duke you are new member
number 10 thank you Lisa I also want to
say thanks to Brandon Smith who is
number whoa things just went haywire who
is number 11 at join pakman.com Morgan
Hanson is new member number 12 and last
but absolutely not least Daniel Relic is
new member number 13
today on my website patreon and website
memberships both count today holy fook
says do you support abolishing the
electoral college now there is a
question I can answer in a non-toxic way
yes I do
yes I do and I have a number of segments
on my youtube channel explaining why
that is my position BK says when will
trumpets prove their patriotism by
volunteering for kovat infection testing
yeah there's plenty of trials where
people are volunteering to get infected
and I'm not aware of any large group of
opener uppers who have been volunteering
fair point
holy fook says David Pakman is a
neoliberal shill far writer okay
mattias germany says do you think pence
is also suffering because of trump I
don't know pence seems to be living in a
fantasy world so I don't it's really
hard for me to know what's going on with
pence I really don't know a couple other
thank you so
on Twitch I want to say thanks to Jay
Medina and Adelina for their
subscriptions Beach Jules has subscribed
with Prime doli 74 is a new subscriber
Lancaster Bill has subscribed karu Salem
is a new twitch subscriber as is Norma
tattoo and Marty bum thirteen thanks
Marty bum very much appreciated ok super
chats continuing to come in
Cameron rifai when this sip ends what
will happen when people get reinfected
again do we have to record in teen
doesn't make sense to me yeah I I think
the most likely scenario is going to be
rolling overlapping openings and
closures in different states that I if
you said not what do I want to see
happen but what do I think is likely to
happen that would be my guess at this
point in time are you tired of him looks
like we're going live here so we will
see the White House is not yet live
c-span is not yet live but it looks like
very very soon ah here we are
so they have so reporters are here there
are reporters they have the TVs so the
TVs may play a large propaganda role for
flags suggests the Meade that this is
going to be there's gonna be a larger
sort of propaganda role here and not
that many questions would be my guess
but we will see we will see how this all
goes my you know here's my instinct guys
just based on what I'm seeing and the
fiasco that was Thursday and Friday
my guess is Trump will come out and make
a speech maybe play a video about
opening the country and leave without
taking questions that's my guess okay
and I hope he takes questions and I hope
that I'm wrong but that's my that's sort
of my instinct right now let me know
what you think thanks to Donna Williams
for the super chat Jen Shutts says news
alert Trump says updog will cure Cove at
19 yeah I think actually Pike position
cares it raw
H says hey David truly appreciate your
livestream thank you I appreciate your
support
Jacob Ratner says if 45 is re-elected do
you fear for us a democracy well yeah I
also fear for Homo sapiens William C
says do you think doctor suicide will
become a huge issue story in The New
York Times top ER doctor who treated
virus patients dies by suicide that's
horrifying I've not read the story but I
will check that out
eclipse has subscribed yeah a lot of
shaky camera there well Oh a few other
members that I should definitely thank
about a second David oh this is good
okay David Berlie is new member number
14 today David Dumas is new member
number 15 you know yesterday I happened
to look up out of curiosity how many
websites member how many website members
do we have named David it's a shocking
number it's a shocking I'm not gonna
tell you the number right now but it is
a shocking number and there's got to be
some self-selection bias right like are
people more likely to become paid
members to a show where the host shares
their first name even if it's
subconscious in some way because the
number of members named David that we
have is shocking shocking
Joshua funder white is new member number
16 today Mehdi visited on is new member
number 17 today Jon Hickson is new
member number 18 Bryan Coble is new
member number 19 today and Kate Katz
Berg Kate Katz Berg Thank You Kate Kate
is new member number 20 today very much
appreciate that we are standing by for
the start of today's Rose Garden press
conference apparently this is being
framed a little bit differently it is
not the standard coronavirus press
briefing it is a rose garden press
conference which to me signals Trump
isn't going to take questions although
when I hear press conference
you know I'm thinking questions in
Trump's world that may mean
press conference instead of press
briefing means the press is allowed
there but they can't ask questions or
something notice oh there are actually
microphones here though okay so maybe
maybe there will be some questions we'll
see okay - seagull - seagull ease says
if something happens to Biden will
Bernie be the Democratic candidate stay
cool David III don't even think that's
uh necessary to address right now
Shannon Bennett says Candace Owens has
developed evolved into a raving pandemic
denier and the amens from her Twitter
followers should worry us all what gives
with this I don't know she has me she's
blocked me tweet she blocked me years
ago on Twitter over the weekend Scott
Adams blocked me on Twitter the Dilbert
cartoonist
because I said that he should just take
the loss on this injection stuff he was
not making any sense you can actually
check out if you look at my Twitter or
his Twitter the entire fiasco but yeah
he blocked me so I don't know what he's
saying and Candace Owens also blocked me
so I don't know what it is that she's
saying Paul JM says if Trump stops
answering questions that these briefings
should the media just stop broadcasting
them yeah I think that would be
reasonable Casey Bates says what level
am i if I signed up for a 240 dollar a
year membership you are David Pakman if
you signed up at that level Casey I very
much appreciate that
squee Dow says thanks for being you
Thank You Matthew Kelly says you're
welcome David I am grateful for what you
do I've been meaning to join for a while
thank you for all you do to bring the
truth to the people thank you
Kristin Miller says thanks for being a
sound voice Adam Waddington says can you
voice the text tweet maybe that's how
Trump's tweets get so many spelling
errors that's conceivable that's
conceivable that's something I've I've
certainly thought about before not at
all inconceivable let me say thank you
to taylor goad who is today's 21st new
member on my website i want to say
thanks to james Quattlebaum who has just
doubled his patreon pledge
Bruce has made a pledge and so has
Brittney Garza win thanks Britney you
our new supporter number 24 today Daniel
Rivera is number 25 and you know as I
like to say let's let's go for 50 I
think we can do it also want to say
thanks to Katherine Leary who has just
upgraded her membership from six to
twelve dollars a month
thanks so much Katherine very much
appreciate it we are in the Rose Garden
at the White House and anticipating
weaponized propaganda and hyperbolic
disinformation any moment I'll be here
with you to try to parse the lies we are
expecting some kind of major
announcement about testing which from
what I've heard could be extremely
underwhelming could be extremely
underwhelming if you're just joining us
there's a rumor that Trump will announce
a plan to test two percent of the
country now we've tested 5.6 million
already two percent of the country is
6.6 million so if the announcement is
we're gonna do a million more tests at
some point that's a very lame
announcement now if the announcement is
we're gonna test 2% each day meaning we
can test the entire country every 50
days that would then become something
notable again it's anyone's guess what
the announcement today is going to be
okay twitch messages and thank yous top
Dylan has subscribed with Prime thank
you Wolff has subscribed squishy lush
face is a new twitch prime subscriber as
this orator 66 Aaron Nance subscribes
and says love everything you do David
how long do you think it will take for
the country to fully reopen again I have
no personal opinion other than what
doctors say and what I'm seeing doctors
say is until there's a vaccine it's
probably not going to be fully back to
normal for lack of a better term LaShawn
has subscribed with Prime and so has
Solly Jim just as a very brief thing
because we're
trying to have some elements of
positivity here is a time lapse of two
hours of my tomato plants over the
weekend look at this little guy right
here just stretching towards the
sunlight isn't that inspirational rising
like a phoenix and I already have a
third sprout today and things are
developing very very quickly I think I
might have a pound tomato by tomorrow
now obviously I'm kidding but things are
developing and maybe I'll do a couple
other pictures later I did I somebody
actually told me you know David pot
plants look the same because I guess
there's some relationship between
cannabis and tomato plants that they
grow in a similarly branching fashion or
something like that and somebody told me
that at this stage a pot plant looks
exactly the same these are not pot
plants these are yellow cherry tomatoes
just a beautiful beautiful thing to see
absolute madness happening and what else
can I say I will I will have updates I
will have updates those are elements of
a tomato though yeah very good okay
Philip Neyman says by saying no state
bailouts isn't Mitch McConnell actually
just priming the come the bud priming
the pump not Kumpf to slash social
services as the condition for receiving
federal funds Mitch I don't know what
Mitch McConnell is doing but I can tell
you it's bad for America we have a track
record from him and we know that that's
the case burning rangers gaming channel
says better candidate in your book
Hillary or Biden I the reason that
that's tough to answer is Hillary in
2020 would be very different than
Hillary in 2016
Biden in 2016 would have been different
than Hillary so I don't know I think the
election is mostly going to be
determined by circumstances I don't
think Biden rather than Hillary or
Hillary rather than Biden in 2020 would
actually be a difference maker
that's my genuine feeling right now okay
other super chats that have been coming
in Daniel Krieger
do you believe Tara Reid I have no
reason to believe that Tara Reid is
saying things that she knows to be lies
and I want way more information way more
information and investigation of the
Tara Reid story which should be taken
seriously as an accuser who has come
forward yeah and I want a big
investigation to be done alright we've
got a bunch of people showing up here
this could be a big business propaganda
thing I'm guessing these are business
leaders and people from different
corporations that Trump is going to
promote that's my my instinct dr. Burks
is here looks like dr. Gerard Merle
Gerard no foul she again huh yeah foul
she's been missing for a very long time
at this point no foul she once again
seems like absolutely no social
distancing whatsoever happening with
these people
interesting keep an eye out there for
dr. foul Qi let me say thank you to
Jeremy shock who has just doubled his
patreon pledge from five to ten dollars
a month also alejandro felix is new
member number 28 today at join
pakman.com and also a big big thank you
to Michael Vivian Michael Vivian is new
member number 29 today at join
pakman.com
I really it's been incredibly
heartwarming to see that as many as
hundreds of members are having to cancel
because of the virus when we do a stream
in 20 30 40 50 people sign up it's
really what's what's allowing us to stay
level I've committed as I said to no
hours reductions or anything like that
and I I can't say how much I appreciate
the support of a view really really nice
people who joined me
almost daily on these streams Jake semi
a says my friend is stationed in Kansas
for the army says the state just opened
up and he said everybody was worrying
for no reason what are your thought what
is no reason I don't I don't even
understand the assertion worrying for no
reason we have an over a million cases
of the virus confirmed Alvaro s says
what will be the political fallout from
the virus will it motivate turnout from
minorities who are disproportionately
impacted by this or will the fact that
we are more impacted depressed
Democratic turnout here's my general
view is that the longer this goes the
worse it is for Trump now you've got to
look at more details right you have to
look at you have to slice and dice it a
little bit more to really understand the
full impact but I think that the longer
the virus continues to be a thing the
worse it is for Donald Trump on balance
and of course there there are micro ways
in which it could be good for Trump like
if Democrats are more scared of the
virus and thus choose to stay home in
larger numbers than Republicans that
what we will deal with Union prodigy
says do the strings on your hoodie hang
at the same length no no that would be a
little weird one is slightly longer all
right here is Trump let's go over to the
feed on c-span we like the angles on
c-span better and we will soon see
Donald Trump enter the only downside is
c-span is just a little bit behind but
trust me it's worth it particularly
because we don't want to play these and
gentlemen what the President of the
United States accompanied by the vice
president ladies and gentlemen the
president of States accompanied by the
vice president of the United States bear
with me folks it's all gonna happen very
very cleanly as soon as it gets going
here is Trump brace yourselves folks
it's gonna be a doozy
thank you very much thank you today I'd
like to provide you with an update the
audio is on a delay I'm gonna refresh
once and otherwise we will bales we've
had such tremendous support all over we
continue to see encouraging signs of
progress cases in New York area
New Orleans Detroit Boston and Houston
are declining Denver Seattle
Philadelphia Washington DC Atlanta
Nashville Indianapolis and st. Louis are
all stable and declining all parts of
the country are either in good shape
getting better in all cases getting
better and we're seeing very little that
we're going to look at as a superseding
hotspot things are moving along really a
horrible situation that we've been
confronted with but they're moving along
as we express our gratitude for these
hard-fought gains however we continue to
mourn with thousands of families across
the country as loved ones have been
stolen from us by the invisible enemy we
grieve by their side as one family this
great American family and we do grieve
we also stand in solidarity with the
thousands of Americans who are ill and
waging a brave fight against the virus
we're doing everything in our power to
heal the sick and to gradually reopen
our nation so you get you can tell from
the language and how he's sticking to
the script so far someone got to him and
said no more [ __ ] no more injections
just read the script therefore getting
our country back and it's happening and
it's happening faster than people would
think ensuring the health of our economy
is vital to ensuring the health of our
nation these goals work in tandem they
work side-by-side
it's clear that our aggressive strategy
to slow the spread has been working and
is saving countless lives
for those who are infected we've taken
unprecedented action to ensure they have
the highest level of care anywhere in
the world the federal government has
built more than 11,000 extra bets
shipped or delivered hundreds of
millions of pieces of personal
protective equipment as you know in fact
some of the people here are going to be
talking about it some of our greatest
executive some of the greatest anywhere
in the world course distributed over
10,000 ventilators and we now have in a
very short period of time many have been
delivered and hundreds of thousands are
being built and frankly every governor
has more ventilators right now than they
know what to do with they're actually
shipping them to different locations and
we're shipping some to our allies and
others throughout the world because we
have ventilators like the job that
they've done in getting this very
complex piece of equipment built is
actually incredible you don't hear about
ventilators anymore except in a positive
way we've launched the most ambitious
testing effort likewise here we go on
earth the United States has now
conducted more than 5.4 million tests
nearly double the number tested in any
other country more than twice as much as
any other country so they promised 20
million by the end of March obviously
that didn't happen were also 41st per
capita and testing Walmart Walgreens CVS
Rite Aid and Kroger we're joined by the
leaders of those great companies and we
also have with us the leaders from the
world's top medical diagnostics
companies and suppliers thermo Fisher
lab core quest u.s. cotton and the
American Clinical Laboratory Association
these are great great companies these
private sector leaders along with others
such as Rose Abbott Becton Dickinson
whole logic and cephei sefa hide seven
exceptional partners in an unprecedented
drive to expand the state's capabilities
and our country's capabilities the job
they've done
been incredible set the testing it's
been developed and being developed right
now is a bingo
truly an amazing thing I want to thank
Abbot laboratories for the job they've
done I want to thank Roshan in
particular those two have really stepped
forward Abbot with a five minute test
that people can take and in five minutes
they know what the what the answer is
I'd like to ask if I could the
executives of these great companies and
they are they have really helped us a
lot over the last 45 day period we're
talking about a 45 day period when many
of us met and since then what Walmart
and the others have done has been
nothing short of amazing so I just want
to ask them to come forward and say a
few words about their company plus
they're going to make a big contribution
to our country please right come forward
please thank you anybody buying stocks
right now Thank You mr. president and
thank you for all of you for being here
today and and what we'd like to talk
about is the progress we made the last
time we were here was March 13th and
we've been tremendous progress and none
of that progress could be made without
the forty-seven thousand people that
quest Diagnostics that are working
around the clock working up the test and
running the test in delivering the
results that we need as far as results
we've made tremendous progress we are
currently at quest Diagnostics testing
about 50000 tests per day we've been
pushed by the task force to bring up
that number by the end of May we'll have
a hundred thousand tests per day about
three million tests and these are the
molecular tests that we do today we've
also brought up serological testing we
started that this past week and by the
end of May we'll be close to 250,000 a
day about 7,000 a month so you put those
two numbers together together it's about
10 million tests by the end of May that
we'll be doing at Qwest diagnosed we're
doing that also in a quicker way toward
around times were somewhat of an issue
at the early days we've reduced that the
one that
days or turn around take time for people
in beds hospital beds is less than 24
hours and we're doing that in the same
way we've done it with the FDA more CLIA
delivering the quality that you all
expect and convenience will improve as
well with convenient solutions that
we'll be able to swab individuals more
easily and also deliver to consumer the
ability to have consumers choose a test
online with a telehealth provider so
with that I like to offer my colleague
the podium as well mr. president thank
you very much for your leadership and
for having us all here today our
scientists and our lab technicians are
working day and night in order to do as
many tests as we possibly can for the
American public and to turn those tests
around as quickly as possible just 45
days ago we said we could do several
thousand tests a day we can now do
60,000 tests a day and we're continuing
to expand that capacity every single day
in addition for summer so we got a
hundred K from this other guy 60 K
that's 160 K to even really have a
conversation we need 500 to a million a
day so okay when is that going to go up
by LabCorp at home test that test right
now is for health care workers on the
front line and first responders but we
will be rolling that out much more
broadly over the coming weeks and we're
gonna roll it out with absolutely no
upfront cost for the individual
consumers at the same time we're
building our capacity for serology
testing and we can currently do about
50,000 today and we'll be able to do
several hundred thousand per day by the
middle of May that we need and we're
gonna be working with the retailers our
colleagues are here today to help them
as they expand their testing
capabilities across the entire country
and lastly mr. president we have a
rather large drug development business
and we will continue to work with our
colleagues in the pharmaceutical and the
biotech naval technology industry to
ensure we do everything we possibly can
to enroll clinical trials fast so we can
get new treatments and potential
vaccines thank you
anybody here like protestors in the back
mr. president thank you and thank and
thank the administration for all of the
collaboration to enable Thermo Fisher
Scientific to be able to produce the
test kits that companies like LabCorp
and quest and the public health labs
around the world run we met our original
commitments of producing five million
kits a week and we're up to scaling that
to double that in the coming weeks yeah
it doesn't tell us about how many people
are being tested by the way is every one
of these CEOs just a white dude world
for their tireless effort to make that a
reality and supporting all of our
customers to have the testing necessary
to get America back to work
who's next Thank You mr. president
I'm John Ames with u.s. cotton and we
are the company that is going to produce
the swabs to be used in these testing
kits we have about 1,200 people in our
company and in our Cleveland operation
they have pivoted from as you've said
the q-tip style swab to a swab that's
going to have a plastic stick with a
polyester tip so that they can be
assembled into these kits our Cleveland
team has done a wonderful job with this
and I'm very they're very excited to be
able to help in this effort so Thank You
mr. president
excellent job a lot of propaganda here
guys
my pills president thank you my malaria
Merlot with CVS health and it was just
over a month ago that we opened up our
first drive-through test site and since
that time we have opened large-scale
tests but it's not really across five
states in partnership with the
administration and working with the
governors of Rhode Island Massachusetts
Connecticut Georgia in Michigan and
these sites are enabling us to test
approximately a thousand individuals a
day with real-time results we now have a
capacity to test about 35,000
individuals each each week and this
afternoon we announced plans to expand
that capacity even further beginning in
May we will install testing capabilities
in up to a thousand CVS pharmacies we'll
be using our drive-throughs and our
parking lots with swab testing so again
you'll see that coming online you know
in May and we also recognize the fact
that you know the virus is
disproportionately affecting our
minority communities so we're working in
partnership with organizations like the
National Medical Association to bring
testing and care into the traditionally
underserved communities we're also
beginning to implement mobile
capabilities with which to do that and
as businesses are you know restarting
their workforce we'll also be looking to
assist them you know as they begin to
come back to a normal operation and
finally as my other colleagues I just
want to thank
my CBS colleagues they have done a
phenomenal job in terms of helping
people in many different ways
all across communities in the country
and they're part of this army of
healthcare professionals and the upfront
store and you know first line
supervisors and workers that are doing
terrific things to bring our country
together and for that we owe them a huge
amount of gratitude thank you just a lot
of CEOs getting to promote their
businesses a very very valuable air time
apparently Thank You mr. president
appreciate the the invitation to be here
today and it was just 45 days ago when
we were here I'm Richard Ashworth I
oversee Walgreens in the US and I just
want to start off Larry like you
thinking the over 200,000 Walgreen team
members who are in stores every day all
across America taking care of our
patients and our customers you know
giving them essential daily needs the
prescriptions obviously that they need
and even kovat testing while we're here
we also announced today we'll be
expanding our testing capabilities
across all states including Puerto Rico
we'll be able to triple the volume that
we do now in lab partners and we're
excited to be able to do that we're
really excited with the public-private
partnership that we have here because
that's what enabling us to do this and
we look forward to working with the
additional states to get these sites up
and running as fast as possible as a
pharmacist I just want to say one quick
thing I'm really proud to be part of
this profession and not just Walgreens
pharmacists and and Pharmacy employees
but all of them across grocery mass
independence you're really doing what
you should be doing and what you went to
school for to help patients counseling
them on their medicines and helping them
understand the problems that we're
facing
you know pharmacy is right here in it
with everyone together in the community
and we look forward to being part of the
testing like we are now serology
whatever that might look like in the
future and eventually treatment when the
vaccine does come so thank you mr.
president for the opportunity thank you
who's next
Thank You mr. president
Thank You mr. vice president we
appreciate all you're doing to get
America back to work and doing it safely
I represent Kroger my name is Rodney
MacMullen and I am so proud of our
nearly half a million associates that
are doing everything every day to keep
customers safe and our associates safe
and one of the things that we were able
to do is provide the basic practices
we're doing we call it blueprint and
it's the things that all of us can learn
from on how to get America back working
we also announced earlier today
continuing to accelerate our practice on
testing we are actively engaged in six
states next in the next couple of weeks
we'll take that to twelve states and the
number of tests that we do continues to
grow faster than that together we will
win together we will solve this problem
and move on America is always great
thank you again right wow it's just a
parade of just CEOs I guess getting
there there a minute mr. president my
name is Doug McMillon I'm a Walmart
associate and I too would like to start
by thanking our associates for
everything that they're doing in our
stores Sam's Clubs distribution centers
and in our e-commerce fulfillment
centers they've been inspiring and
continue to have a can-do attitude and
step up it's much appreciated
we started 45 days ago as did everyone
else and we've been operating sites for
a while now we're now up to 20 sites
across 11 states by the end of next week
we'll be 245 and by the end of the May
end of May we'll be at a hundred we also
a few weeks ago vice president Pence and
I were in a distribution center in
Virginia food distribution center he was
kind enough to come and thank our
associates for us there which is much
appreciated and the president vice
president were speaking on the phone
about surgical gowns and the president
asked if we could put in an order for a
millions of surgical gowns and we don't
normally buy those so I wasn't sure if
we were going to be able to do that but
I'd like to thank our apparel team and
McKesson in particular for partnering
with us we've been able to in the month
of April secured an additional two and a
half million surgical gowns and by the
end of May we'll have an additional six
million available to help so thank you
for the opportunity to serve
and for being here right
Thank You mr. president hey sometimes in
a way we're getting this great operation
up and running for the benefit of the
country I'm Hayward Donegan with Rite
Aid and we are currently operating 40%
of the current test sites in 25
locations across eight states and we had
the I had the opportunity as I was
driving up to stop at our Richmond
location and see the testing in action
and thanked the associates whether it be
security or pharmacy front and everybody
who's helping with this great effort and
all of the customers that appreciate
this so much it was really amazing to
see and I want to thank my 50,000
associates also for keeping these retail
locations up and running during these
really really tough times it's been
quite amazing and we too are going to
expand our testing and we're doing about
1,500 a day thanks okay how many more I
guess not you all very much it's
incredible what we've done together over
a short period of time I want to thank
our vice president for the task force
and the work every day gets better and
we had a fantastic call with the
governor's today and I would say that
they are as thrilled as they can be
considering that the fact is that there
has been so much unnecessary death in
this country it could have been stopped
that it could have been stopped short
but somebody a long time ago it seems
decided not to do with that way oh and
the whole world is suffering because of
it 184 countries at least but I want to
thank all of these great business men
and women for the job they've done they
have been fantastic with us working with
us and as you know for several weeks my
administration's encouraged the
governor's to leverage unused testing
capacity and States for if you
understood that we have tremendous
capacity then one week ago we provided
each governor with a list of names
addresses and phone numbers of the labs
where they could find additional testing
capacity in their states
we
then 48 hours the number of tests
performed of course the country began to
absolutely skyrocket on Saturday alone
more than 200,000 test results were
reported which is a gigantic number
bigger than any country anywhere in the
world for a much longer period of time
not per capita number that is an
increase earlier in the month when we
tested roughly less than 100,000 a day
so we much more than doubled it and that
will be doubling again very shortly we
are continuing to rapidly expand our
capacity and confident that we have
enough testing to begin reopening and
the reopening process we want to get our
country open we actually don't and the
testing is not going to be a problem at
all I think it's going to be one of the
great assets that we have today we're
releasing additional guidance on testing
to inform the states as they develop
their plans for phased and very safe
reopening ok our blueprint describes how
states should unlock their full capacity
expand the number of testing platforms
established monitoring systems to detect
local outbreaks and conduct contact
tracing we have it all other countries
are calling to find out what are we
doing and how do we do it and we're
helping them we're dealing with a lot of
countries helping them on testing if
they're calling it to a voice like we
did on the ventilators I directed our
Medicare program to make it easier for
seniors to get the testing that they
need and the pharmacies as you know we
are allowing pharmacies now to do
testing and we have other testing
locations that we're going to be
allowing also but having pharmacies get
involved in testing is a very big deal
we're also asking governor's to do the
same in their Medicaid program so
they're going to be able and authorized
to do the same and Medicaid so it's a
big that's a big deal so we're deploying
the full power and strength of the
federal government to help States cities
to help local government get this
horrible plague over with and over with
fast there's tremendous energy in our
country right now there's energy like
people haven't seen in a long time
spirit that they have not seen and we're
doing very well very well considering
what happened to us and considering if
you look at what happened to others this
is something that the world has not seen
for a long long time you can probably go
back to 1917 where it was a terrible
period of time you all know what
happened in 1917 that's over a hundred
years ago with that I'd like to
introduce if I might dr. Burks if you
could come up and then as well you'll
come up and between the two of you
you'll explain the entire process and
how much progress we've made and where
we're going I remember that Burks can no
longer be trusted just remember that
Thank You mr. president
so the blueprint lays out the roles and
responsibilities to enhance our
partnership between the private sector
and the public sector bringing together
state and local governments with the
federal government to ensure that we can
accomplish and achieve our core
principles and objectives we can have
the first slide the core elements of the
testing plan include both three elements
robot robust diagnostic testing plans
developed in partnerships with state and
I just really want to thank the
governor's and health officials both of
the state and local levels who've been
working with us day and night to work
through these issues and also all the
laboratory directors in many of the
states as well as the American Society
for Microbiology who've been working
with us to ensure that the plans were
efficient and effective within the
robust diagnostic testing plans it was
really unlocking the full capacity of
the state increasing the number of
testing platforms we now have multiple
tests for different platforms increasing
the ability to collect samples
increasing testing and laboratory
supplies and ensuring that we work
together to make sure that every client
receives the tests that they need this
is added with timely monitoring symptoms
and what do I mean by that systems where
we bring together the ability to not
only diagnose the symptomatic but
program proactively and interactively
work with individuals that we know are
at higher risk we've worked with States
to look at where the outbreaks have
occurred
when they're not in the large metro so
just as a reminder while people because
what she's saying is actually
meaningless what really matters now is
when will we be testing 500k a day when
will we be set up for proper contact
tracing
she's only telling us essentially things
we know and things states are being told
with no actual details this is not worth
very much in local governments to ensure
that every symptomatic case and
critically the asymptomatic cases are
quickly tracked and traced to ensure
that we can not only control this
epidemic but predict outbreaks before
they expand and then finally the plan
includes approach of using science and
technology to develop even newer
platforms more efficient testing really
ensuring that the antibody tests that
are utilized and recommended by both FDA
and CDC have high quality and predicting
both exposure to the virus and antibody
development and then finally working on
innovative tests that could be high
throughput and point-of-care an antigen
based test or a point-of-care expanded
not announcing thank you isn't even said
when will we have more tests
[Music]
so who thinks Trump leaves without
taking questions Thank You mr. president
Thank You ambassador birx if I could
have the next slide please
want to spend just a couple minutes
about telling going over where we've
been but more importantly where we're
going I think we all can understand how
we can group this into three distinct
phases over seven days are the ones when
we were really engaging the emerging
epidemic and the types of things we need
to do for example mobilize the private
sector to develop tests and have EU A's
and I think you know over the past two
months the FDA has issued 67 emergency
use authorization x'
which is far outpacing anything that has
been done or could ever been imagined
galvanizing the research community in
the commercial labs the reason why we're
here with ACL a labs having done about 3
million tests is because of that day
when it was galvanized by the President
and the Vice President we also set
models in the community those first
community-based testing sites that were
federally supported and really under the
direction of the US Public Health
Service people who had been in Japan
testing people on the diamond princess
to assure that it would be done right
and it would be done safely for everyone
involved then we moved to really scaling
that phase was very very important
because we knew we needed to be at an
immense scale to enter the third phase
about supporting opening the way you
think about whether this is fluff is you
think about is anything being said that
would be newsworthy or worth the
reporting him telling us what's happened
over the last eight months eight weeks
either accurately or not accurately is
not news and that's how you can tell
that this is just filler gaslighting
it's of scientific community being able
to broaden the types to spun polyester
so us cotton can now come in and start
delivering within the next couple of
weeks three million swabs per week of a
different type it also did things like
expanding the community-based testing
sites where as we started small with the
commercial partners you see today right
now we have 73 of this 2.0 sites going
to 110 and very importantly this
demonstrated the model and 68% of those
are in communities of moderate or high
social vulnerability and 22% are in the
highest social vulnerability communities
so that we can make sure the testing
gets where it needs to be you've just
heard that that could be expanded to
thousands of sites and finally stage 3
which is very exciting coordinating with
governor's to support testing plans and
rapid response programs over the past
week a multidisciplinary team from the
White House HHS FDA FEMA has met
virtually with multidisciplinary teams
from every state Puerto Rico and the
District of Columbia to understand what
they're testing aspirations are and to
make sure that we can meet those demands
we're gonna have another round of those
calls this week but as we talked about
earlier today we will be able to supply
every state with the with the supplies
and the tests that they need that will
dramatically increase the number of
tests we've done what will be those to
give you an idea yes the supplies that
we will be providing to States the
minimum that we're supplying to States
is approximately double in that month
then the Republic of Korea has performed
and the four months do now accumulate
what gave you an idea of the amount
tests we need to do 500k minimum and
ideally 2 million a day how many what
but that's it's twice what Korea did
last month what poor inquest providing
the very high throughput large-scale
testing the galvanizing of the hospitals
and academic labs that dr. Burks has
done by a machine to machine
understanding and promoting that with
the governors and of course using
point-of-care testing when and where
that's very important to stop outbreaks
or in remote areas like in the Indian
Health Service or in Alaska Thank You
mr. president
all right does he take questions okay so
with that we're here to answer some
questions and Mike is up here also so
Steve please go ahead here we go
and how to open their states what's the
best advice from you on what we want
them to do it we recommend that they do
it as quickly as possible but safely we
want everyone to be safe and I think
you're seeing that you're seeing a lot
of governor's get out and they want to
open it up many are thinking about their
school system not a long way to go in
the school system right now for this
season for this year but I think you'll
see a lot of schools open up even if
it's for a very short period of time I
think it would be a good thing because
as you see and I don't think then that
would be horrible what this vicious
virus goes after young people seem to do
very well young people seem to do very
well so I know that there are some
governor's that aren't necessarily ready
to open up their states but they may be
ready to open up their school systems
we'll see but that's their choice but
the word is safety okay wrap it but
safety yeah please go ahead please
a virus task force and that's Secretary
of HHS Alex nazar yeah on January the
28th he was in the briefing room and in
the briefing room he told reporters that
for the individual American the virus
should not be an impact on their
day-to-day life three months later
more than 55,000 of our fellow American
I like it now lost their lives right mr.
president why is he still yours top
health advisor why is he still serving
as the HHS secretary oh that's a very
unfair question because you've got many
great professionals some of them you
have great respect for and you have many
people in the other party you mentioned
Alex Heiser yeah but they don't work
many people in the other party that have
said the same thing and didn't have
confidence yeah so didn't work didn't
get that right irrelevant I was I was
very fortunate weather was through luck
or whatever that we closed the border we
put a ban on China other than our
citizens coming in we had our citizens
you can't keep out American citizens a
good question come back into your
country that's a little tough to do but
we put a ban on China that was very
fortunate but I could tell you that
Nancy Pelosi was dancing in the debate
he doesn't have Nancy Pelosi light but
he doesn't have Nancy Pelosi running the
response right that's the question so
you don't mention that but you could
mention she doesn't work for go ahead
any other please go ahead you should
have no complaints quote inflate
inflated the mortality rate of the
coronavirus by underreporting the
infection rate do you believe that's
true that there's some sort of
conspiracy theories like it Ronnie the
number of infections they yes well I can
only say what we're doing we're
reporting very accurately if you look at
other countries other countries are not
I mean you can look at China you can
look at numerous countries where I don't
think those are right numbers I can only
say what we're doing it's very important
to us to do very accurate reporting and
that's what we're doing John go ahead
please
thank you place on mr. president one
asked you about a payment protection
plan holy-shit help no one asks about an
election terms they it will be because
they were warned right I mean there must
be I can't even imagine why there
wouldn't be a question about that well I
just came out and I hadn't heard I heard
there was a glitch we'll find out
whether or not that so certainly it did
work out very well for the original
amount of money this is the second
moment and I'll find out about that will
fund we're relying on the banks to go
out and do an accurate job yet police in
the back well I wouldn't mind doing that
I don't know what the legal status of
something like that I would like to do
that as far as I'm concerned I'm not
involved in that process but I would
certainly like to have it listed I'd
have to find out if there's a legal
problem but if there isn't I would do it
loudly please a majority of polls show
that Americans believe China for the
spread of the coronavirus pipe and yet
they're taking advantage of the crisis
to make the world more dependent on
their supply chains how do you get how
do you hold China accountable and get
this guy out of here keep our country
well tell you there are a lot of ways
you can hold them accountable we're
doing very serious investigations as you
know what an alpha question and we are
not happy with China we are not happy
with that whole situation because we
believe it could have been stopped at
the source and stopped quickly and it
wouldn't have spread all over the world
that we think that should have happened
so we'll let you know what the
appropriate time but we are doing
serious investigations well we've
already discussed that and especially
having to do with medical supplies and
others and others if you look prior to
this virus the deficit was coming way
down under my administration because I
put massive tariffs on China
tens of billions of dollars gave some of
it to the farmers who were unfair like
nobody's ever done that before we never
took intensity now all of a sudden I
think you know very well we've taken in
tens of billions of dollars we've taken
in my help the farmers by giving him two
years ago twelve billion
all coming from China it's letting
leftover to weep and then the following
year 16 billion and this year we're also
going to help our farmers but nobody's
ever done a thing like that because they
were targeted unfairly by China so we're
doing a very strong investigation and
we'll let you know what the result of
that is how would you be able to get the
answers to as you talk about potentially
reopening up America again as we see in
the slides behind you what data are you
gonna look at in the future how is there
not a question about to be reimpose yeah
we're looking very much and reliant very
much in the local areas the government
blackmailed and that's been the way it
has reading for me maybe not for
everybody but for me that's the way it's
been at the beginning and from the
beginning the governor's some of them
are doing an extraordinary job not all
of them but some of them and I think all
of them maybe has it have a chance to do
that some will be a little bit different
the areas are much different Manhattan
is much different than Montana you have
a lot of different circumstances but and
obviously if you look at the virus it
hit some areas hasn't hit very much
other areas not even at all almost not
at all but the entire country has been
infected West Virginia as an example I
spoke to Jim Justice the governor of
West Virginia and they were a long
before anything hit and they had
numerous deaths even in West Virginia
and they were really the last one to be
hit so we're dealing with the governor's
we had a really great call today as I
told you very very solid these are these
were not complaining people this was
anybody asked if they had everything
their ventilators they have their
testing they see their testing is
growing they're growing they're testing
we're helping them we're getting them
that what they need and that was a group
I wish I mean I'm sure some of you are
on the line even though you were
supposed to be and I think you know what
the result of that call was please go
ahead
question I'm making change China holding
them responsible Germany's Senate bill
to China 430 Dillian dollars excuse me
under 30 billion euros
for the damages caused by the Toyota
virus would your administration look at
doing the same well we could do
something much easier than that we have
ways of doing things a lot easier than
that but Germany's looking at things
that we're looking at things and we're
talking about a lot more money than
Germany's talking about yeah please go
ahead we haven't determined the final
value very substantial if you look at
the world I mean this is worldwide
damage this is damage to the US but this
is damage to the world yeah please she's
also not asking about when you'd have to
ask Attorney General bar but I think he
wants to see like everybody he wants to
see people get back and wants to see
people get back to work he doesn't want
people to be held up when there's no
reason for doing it in some cases
perhaps it's too strict he wants to make
sure people have their rights and they
maintained their rights very importantly
so a lot of people would agree with him
but you'd actually have to ask that
question specifically from a legal
standpoint to Attorney General bar
it would depend on the state it would
depend on the circumstances of the state
but some states are you know perhaps a
little early and some states are a
little bit late and the Attorney General
I read that and I saw that and frankly
the Attorney General doesn't want to
have rights taken away cuz you know
there are some people they're not
allowed to open up a store or you're
gonna lose their livelihood and by the
way that causes death also between all
of the things that happen and this has
been a big study you know the fact that
people aren't allowed to have their
freedom causes tremendous amount of
problems including death so that's what
he's talking about please in the back
[Music]
using disinfectant yes after your
comments last week I know you said they
were sorry I can't imagine why I can't
imagine why yeah I can't imagine I can't
imagine that yeah go ahead please dr.
Anthony Fauci says that we need to
increase testing by double in at least
so does the Rockefeller Foundation when
are we going to well that it doesn't
really matter what they say there and we
just left him we just had a meeting but
because we're gonna have much more than
doublet very soon now there are big
believers in testing and then there are
some governors that don't feel as
strongly about it at all you understand
that they feel much differently about it
but we're going with maximum testing
because it's something we're very
capable of doing but we'll be much more
than doubled you know Mike I'd like you
to answer that we're going to be much
higher than doubled on testing very
shortly Mike please
Thank You mr. president
I hope the American people looking on
today are as proud as the president and
I are of the incredible public and
private partnership that you heard from
today if the other breath it was two
months ago that we had done less than
10,000 tests for the corona virus okay
I'm muting and I'm taking over here
because this is weaponized
disinformation so here's the deal they
told us that by the end of March 20
million tests would have been done that
date came and went and they didn't do it
we now have done a total of 5.6 million
tests per capita we are 41st in the
world in testing in order to really be
looking at opening these are the numbers
they will never tell you they just like
that Admiral Jarrar said next month
we'll be doing twice as many tests as
South Korea last month like it was
completely incoherent step one is we're
testing about 180 a day we got to get to
five hundred five hundred thousand a day
absolute minimum really to feel pretty
good we need to be testing a million a
day and ideally more like two million a
day one roadmap says we need to be doing
22 million tests per day we're doing a
hundred and eighty thousand on average
180,000 so private public partnership
you know air bridge is bringing tests
we've scheduled tests to look nut we've
got reagent Jared Kushner yesterday on
Fox News talking about it all that
matters is how many tests are being done
and as you can see here the number today
declining to only a hundred and
thirty-five thousand we're nowhere close
and they seem unwilling to just give us
these numbers I'm getting messages from
people that the twitch stream is down
twitch seems to have gone down it's not
just our stream things are up and down
we can't really do too too much about
that let's go back a little bit to
Pence's posturing and but an only one
question on bleach I cannot believe it
yes to enter phase one to begin to
reopen there
enemies mr. president with your
permission I'll just as Admiral derartu
give some specific numbers about my god
about how quick for all that we've done
how much more quickly you'll see an
expansion of testing because of the
partnership let's see if you witness
again here today mr. vice president the
number of tests that need to be done
depends on the state level you
understand that places where there's
high virus circulating we'll need many
many more tests places that do not have
high virus circulating may need less
tests but lets us assume dr. foutch ii
was talking about about a four million
per month number which was sort of a
week ago where we where we are so we
will according to the governor's plans
for next month we will easily double
that four million number we will have
over 20 million swabs that we're gonna
send out we will have over 15 million
tubes of media we have all the tests
matched machine-to-machine in a focused
area we've gone state-by-state and
understand that we need 15 million tests
per month minimum the five million per
month test by LabCorp and quest or the
point-of-care test by abbott or all the
other tests that are out there so in May
we are going to be doing more testing in
this country and people talk about South
Korea a lot the state the states with
the least amount of testing will double
the overall cumulative number per capita
that South Korea has done in four months
Walgreens CVS Diagnostics but we sat
here in the Rose Garden back on March 13
these companies were here some other
companies were here by my count only 69
drive-through test sites have been set
up by the companies that were here I'm
wondering if you of course mr. vice
president back in early March you said
we'd be at four million a test by the
following week just now got their last
few days right what have you learned
about what went wrong now at once and a
half of the last month and a half or two
months and what's going to go right now
what lessons have you learned from the
mistakes mistakes John I appreciate the
question but it represents a
misunderstanding right on your part and
and frankly the a lot of people are
talking spar about the difference
between having a test versus the ability
to actually process the test we know I
mean the truth was when the president
tapped me to lead the White House
coronavirus Task Force two months ago we
saw the production of lots of test kits
going into the marketplace but as the
president has said many times what he
understood early on was the old system
would never be able to process the tests
at the massive volume it was made in the
midst of an epidemic it was Obama's
fault and that's why the president
brought together these extraordinary
commercial labs that you heard from
today literally sat them down in the
Roosevelt Room and said we need you to
tell the hell didn't bomb a have a
testing system and response in place for
something that didn't happen under his
watch other than the fact that he tried
to Train Trump's administration on how
to deal with the pandemic and left them
a color-coded 69 page playbook which
they threw in the trash and disbanded
the pandemic response team Wow slow
laboratory that is are still conducting
tests today whether it be at the CDC or
at state laboratories but what the
president brought about with this
public-private partnership yeah his
knowledge to the point where we've done
5.4 million tests to date and you
promised 20 million later just heard
that by next month it could we could be
doing as many as 2 million tests a week
all across the country to give the
American people confidence that we can
reopen and get our economy moving again
seven weeks ago you were just talking
about tests being sent out not actually
being being completed exactly John I
think they're precisely correct that in
my first week on this job and how is it
useful to talk about just shipping tests
if people can't actually get them it's
amazing now he's saying that's exactly
what I was saying before million and and
we believe they did but again those were
tests that we're not correctly but for
the president's leadership we'd still be
waiting on those tests to be done in
many cases because they were tests that
were designed you should be glad we were
even sending around tests that couldn't
be used on at the president's Direction
we brought in these incredible
commercial labs we partnered with these
extraordinary retailers and now we stand
here today literally one day last week
more than 200,000 tests in a single day
about the time that that we were making
those comments we'd we'd done less than
25,000 tests and you had no idea what
you're talking but we've met this moment
with American ingenuity with the
incredible companies our representative
a more proud it's very important to know
and this you can get from any other
country I think if they're being honest
not only do we have the most testing in
the world by far but we have by far the
best testing OAM please
general he may well be fully exonerated
this week if that were if that were the
case why a reason why you would not
bring him back into the administration I
will only say this I think that general
Flynn is a wonderful man oh my he had a
wonderful career and it was a disgrace
what happened to Jenny let's see what
happens now
but what happened did general Flynn
should never happen again in our country
what happened to me never happened again
in our country what happened to your
President of the United States should
never again be allowed to happen
Wow
mr. president thank you today one of
your top economic advisors said you said
that the u.s. is likely to experience
20 to 30% decline in the GDP in the
second quarter the worst since the Great
Depression do you agree with that
assessment I don't know but I can tell
you the third and the fourth quarter in
particular are gonna be I think
spectacular we were talking about it
with the executives I think they have a
phenomenal third quarter nobody you know
except one country can be held
accountable for what happened nobody's
blaming anybody here we're looking at a
group of people that should have stopped
it at the source but so what happens and
second happens in second what we are
doing is I think we're gonna have you
can see a big rise in the third but
you're gonna see an incredible fourth
quarter and you're gonna have an
incredible next year I think you're
gonna have a recovery look I built they
were just telling me inside a grand it's
fact I built the greatest economy with
the help of three hundred and twenty
five million people I built the greatest
economy and the history of the world
right and one day because of something
that should have never been allowed to
happen we had to close our country when
it closed our economy I built it
we had the best employment numbers and
the best unemployment numbers for
Hispanic American for African American
for Asian American for everybody best
stock market numbers and by the way the
stock market was up very substantially
today and people are seeing a lot of
good things a lot of very smart people
investing in the stock market right now
it's a 24,000 approximately 24,000 and
if you would have said with the tragedy
that this country had to endure and go
through with all of the death and the
people that died and were so badly hurt
by what happened and you can only say
God bless them but if you would have
said that our country would be in the
position where now we're ready to move
forward we'll never forget loved ones
will never forget these great people
that sacrifice for a reason of
incompetence or something else other
than incompetence what happened at a
point
could have protected the whole world not
just us the whole world but we had the
greatest economy ever in the history of
our world and I had to turn it off in
order to get to a point where we are
today and now we're making a comeback
and I think we're going to have
economically from an economic standpoint
next year an unbelievable year hopefully
he won't and I think that you're gonna
see a fantastic fourth quarter and the
third quarter will start to build but
the second quarter obviously you're
gonna have GDP lack of growth I'm
looking at the head of Walmart what a
job Walmart's done in going through
something I mean they were they were
doing yeoman's work including getting us
millions of yeoman really very very
protective outfits and and Mel did the
job that Doug and Walmart did was
incredible millions of outfits and those
are high-quality I've seen them those
are high-quality that's what we need Sao
Paulo stepped up to the plate I think
we're gonna have a really good I think
it's gonna start building I think it's
gonna build fast I think it'll be a
tremendous tremendous comeback and you
know so I say I built the greatest
economy with all of the people that I
know the question was do you expect down
20 to 30% in q2 that was the question
five minutes ago again and it's not
gonna be that long okay yes opening up
the country how long will you will keep
optics weather restrictions pretty good
well we're looking at that and it
depends on how long it's taking Europe
to heal Italy is starting to make a
comeback I'm very happy to see that with
my friend the Prime Minister's it's
tragic what went on in Italy and Spain
and France and Germany frankly in every
every country over there it's tragic but
we'll be looking at what's happening in
Europe and certainly we want to do that
and they want to do it too they want to
do it very badly yeah
so you had any update on Tim jong-un's
health does he responded to your letter
from March when kim jeong-hoon I can't
tell you exactly yes I do have a very
good idea but I can't talk about it now
I just wish him well I've had a very
good relationship with Kim jong-un if I
weren't president you'd be in war you
would have been in war with Korea that's
untrue he would have been in war with
North Korea if I wasn't president that I
can tell you Hillary Clinton had no
appetite for war with North Korea it's a
joke I hope he's fine I do know how he's
doing relatively speaking we will see
you'll probably be hearing in the
not-too-distant future I wonder two more
election yeah you're a likely Democratic
opponent Joe Biden recently suggested
that you were considering changing the
date of the election that you might try
something like that that's my first
question the same I never even thought
of changing the date of the election why
would I do that November 3rd it's a good
number no I look forward to that
election and death that was just made-up
propaganda not by him but by some of the
many people that are working writing
little statements I see all the time
statement made you say so statement made
per Joe Biden sleepy Joe he didn't make
those statements but somebody did but
they said he made it no let him know I'm
not thinking about it at all
not at all
my Carson Senate Intelligence Committee
came out with the fourth installment of
its report it concluded that Russia
interfered in the 2016 elections and
that was not political bias do you
accept its conclusions oh I don't know I
haven't seen the report I haven't seen
the
but lastly part of the agenda through
Karina he mentioned if the boxing news
he didn't say anything last Saturday no
nobody knows where he is so he obviously
couldn't have said anything about Lila
Moran this is breaking news that Kim
jong-un read a statement on Saturday I
know okay go ahead let's do let's do one
more please so yeah we've lost a lot of
people but if you look at what original
projections were 2.2 million
we're probably heading to 60,000 70,000
far too many 100 subs too many for this
every week now let's say it's gonna be
like 70 80 70 80 deja was closing the
border or doing the band people coming
in from China obviously other than
American citizens which had to come in
can't say you can't come in you can't
come back to your country I think we've
made a lot of good decisions I think
that Mike Pence and the task force have
done a fantastic job I think that
everybody working on the ventilators you
see what we've done there have done
unbelievable the press doesn't talk
about ventilators anymore right they
just don't want to talk about them and
that's okay but the reason they don't
want to talk that was a subject that
nobody would get off of they don't want
to talk about them we're in the same
position on testing we are lapping the
world on testing and the world is coming
to us as I said they're coming to us
saying what are you doing how do you do
it we're helping them so no I think
we've done a great job and one person I
will say this one person is too many
thank you all very much thank you thank
you go to South Korea to get 500,000
test
okay so one last extra there's always
one that someone has to yell out that
one about the I believe that was the
Maryland governor who had to order tests
from South Korea Wow how was there only
one question about bleach injections how
was there only one question were they
warned absolutely stunning and
unbelievable please remember especially
if you were watching on YouTube please
make that subscribe button explode on
your way out
we are tracking to hit a hundred and
thirty thousand subscribers tonight we
could hit 830 subscribers and
subscribers right now and I'm talking
like you guys know what I'm talking
about right now if some of you find
folks watching on YouTube hit that
subscribe button and the like button
I prefer both we were told that these
press briefings were going to be pared
back none on Saturday none on Sunday one
today we will see weather tomorrow there
are any of these that happen or are
scheduled for subsequent days if they
are I will be here otherwise new clips
publishing every 90 minutes on YouTube
thanks for joining me today
you